d'accord Benjamin je vais te poser une de
nos questions les plus révélatrices car tous
nos stagiaires ne veulent pas que tu aimes ne
veulent pas vraiment penser à bien ou tu
te vois dans 10 ans quand j'aurai 80 ans
des conseils avant moi  allez
donc détester les gens ne clignez pas des yeux ça l'épuise
salut Jules je suis Ben ton nouveau stagiaire
je suis content que tu vois aussi l'humour dans ça
être difficile à ne pas je te connaîtrai et j'ai
quelque chose à faire pour toi
J'attendrai de vos nouvelles, monsieur, terriblement désolé,
alors vous êtes le nouveau chauffeur de Jules, en fait, je suis
son directeur de stage, m.
convivialité tout le monde les aime tu
devrais t'habiller pour impressionner rentrer dans la
chemise pourquoi personne ne rentre
plus rien nos investisseurs pensent juste
qu'un PDG chevronné pourrait vous enlever certaines choses
laissez-moi me donner des leçons de PDG dans lesquelles je n'ai jamais rien eu de
tel  ma vie cette grande et
belle chose excitante que tu as
créée souviens-toi qui a fait ce bon moment
c'est des moments comme celui-ci quand tu as besoin de
quelque chose sur lequel tu sais que tu peux compter
parce que tu es mon stagiaire j'allais dire
interniste slash meilleur ami puissance chance
génération les hommes sont partis  de gars comme
Jack Nicholson et Harrison Ford pour
vous vaciller